-♪♪ "Tonight Show" Bar Curling ♪♪
-Now, Jason and I are
going to need some teammates.
So it is my honor to introduce
two of the best curlers
in the world.
Please give a warm
"Tonight Show" welcome
to U.S. Olympic curling team
superstars
and real-life siblings,
Becca and Matt Hamilton,
ladies and gentlemen!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How you doing, Matt?
-Thank you.
-You're going down.
-No way, man. No way.
I'm so happy.
Honored to have you here.
That's Jason Sudeikis.
Welcome to the show.
-Guys, your musical is amazing.
-No, no, that --
-Thank you, thank you.
I wrote it myself.
-No, these are Olympians.
These are --
-Different Hamiltons.
-Gotcha. Haven't seen it.
They weren't in that "Hamilton."
I've got to say,
not only is it odd enough
to be brother and sister,
but you're also
Olympic athletes.
But you're also competing
together
in the first-ever mixed doubles
in Olympic curling history.
-There we go.
-That is what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're rooting for you.
Rooting for U.S.A., baby.
All right,
here's how our game works.
At the end of each
of our bar curling tables
is a bull's-eye with
different point values.
Normally, a curling stone looks
like this guy right here.
-Be careful.
Use your knees.
-Ooh. God.
This is really heavy.
Yeah, using my knees.
-Use your legs.
Use your back.
-We're going to be playing --
We're going to be playing
with this.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to slide
our mini curling stones
towards the bull's-eye,
and we get the point value
for the highest circle
that they're touching.
Okay? If your opponent knocks
you off your curling stone,
you lose those points.
So, we'll each go three times.
Becca and I
will be on the red team.
Jason and Matt
are on the blue team.
Let's take our positions.
Here we go.
-This one?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Matt.
-Yep.
Let's do it.
-What was that?
-Oh, that's just
being teammates.
-But what did he say to you?
-He said, "Let's beat 'em."
-"Let's beat 'em"?
-Yeah.
-Not going to happen.
-Come on, let's do it, pal.
We can do this.
All right, here we go.
To start,
it's Jason versus Becca.
Becca, whenever you're ready,
you go first.
Jason, you got a line
back there.
Yeah, yeah.
That's how you do it.
That's it. That's it.
Teammate!
That's how you do it
right there. Look at that.
Real good.
-We can beat that.
-Get there!
-Ooh.
Slow down, slow down!
-Bite!
-All right. All right.
-It's a tie game!
This is exciting!
This is what I'm talking about!
-Whoo!
-Yeeeeeah!
Yes!
-All right.
All right.
-Yeah, yeah.
Makes it real tricky.
-Lot of room on that 10
for this guy.
-Yeah, I don't know, man.
Here we go, here we go.
-Ooh, go home.
-Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-Get there! Get there!
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh, nothing!
Nothing.
Not even touching.
-Now I've got to thread
the needle. Okay.
-There you go.
Look at this. Look at this.
Oh, that's touching.
That's another point for us.
This is fantastic.
Here we go.
♪♪♪♪
-Uh-oh.
-Get there!
-No, no!
[ Audience ohs ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
-All right.
So it's three to five.
Okay?
And we are in the lead.
You feeling good, bro?
-I'm feeling confident.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, we got this.
Three to five. Here we go.
-Come on, here we go, baby.
-Here we go.
Your turn.
You go first, Matt.
-Yeah, I'll lead you off.
-Curl this son of a gun.
[ Light laughter ]
Get curly.
♪♪♪♪
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a tenner.
-That's a tenner?
-Your move.
-Yeah.
-Take it out.
-All right. All right.
-Oh, geez.
-Oh!
Pretty good, pretty good.
-I forgot we could hit theirs.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪♪♪
-Look at this.
Unrelenting.
-All right.
-Double takeout.
-"Double takeout."
-Oh, no!
-Oh, it was way outside.
-Sorry, sorry, sorry about that.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not funny.
Come on.
That's not funny.
-You know what, I haven't seen
this many curlers in one room
since the Tyler Perry museum
in Atlanta.
-Oh, I moved it off.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
If you land on the 10, we win.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, I can land on 10 and win?
-Yeah, just land --
Just go ahead
and land on the 10.
-Oh, geez.
-Ooh, this is --
[ Audience ohs ]
-It's a tie!
That is a tie right there!
This is good!
Tiebreaker!
No pressure!
Each player throws one.
Each player curls one.
So, what do you call this?
The rock?
-Stone.
-The stone, thank you.
You curl -- Each player
curls one, only one.
This is the game.
-This is it.
-This is it right here.
-Can you throw a takeout?
-Becca, you go first.
-Ooh, a takeout?
-No, no takeouts.
-No takeouts.
Come on.
-All right, all right.
-Everybody knows that!
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
-No, no, this is great!
This is great!
All you need is one!
-I'm going for the 10.
Go big or go home.
-Yes, he went too --
-He got it.
-Oh, my God!
They won right there!
-[ Laughs ]
-Matt!
Congratulations.
Jason Sudeikis...
-Good win. Good win.
-...Matt Hamilton
are the champs.
Becca. Please.
You're the real champ,
right there.
My thanks to U.S. Olympians
Becca and Matt Hamilton.
History will be made
when they compete
in the 2018 Winter Olympics,
which begin February 8th
right here on NBC.